whoever you are wherever you are you can
get involved European Union institutions
have poured enormous resources into
get-out-the-vote campaigns but have they
invested enough in stay out of the vote
efforts in ways to prevent malicious
meddling it's not like there was no
warning five years ago the Kremlin's
internet research agency in st.
Petersburg was revealed estimated to
spend more than a million dollars a
month pumping out anti Western spin
three years ago US elections were the
target of that Russian troll farm yet
the European Commission waited until
just six months before the European
Parliament elections to launch its
action plan against disinformation we
should have been doing much more Jakub
kolinsky spent three years in the
European Commission's East Stratcom
task force a communications unit created
in 2015 to counter Russian efforts to
smear the EU now with an independent
think-tank kolinsky says Brussels is way
behind expecting that we will solve the
problem like in the last two months
before the elections or even in the last
month of the elections when the Russians
have been working on it for the past
five years I think it's very naive
Facebook of Google and Twitter have a
role in the Commission's plan pressed to
better verify users identities and
remove fake accounts faster and to make
clear who's paying for advertising and
content Facebook has just opened its own
war room in Dublin to target inauthentic
activity ahead of EP elections Lutz
gildner from the --use external Action
Service says there has been progress
it's not as much as we would have liked
to but we have seen in terms of
transparency rules things are really
moving and I think the platform's
understood that they also need to take a
much closer look at what is happening
there but not everyone is counting on
bureaucrats and big tech to lead the
battle out in the quiet Flemish
countryside is what you might call an
anti troll farm with a staff of one
[Music]
Martin Schenk debunks false online
stories on his own website lead stories
dot-com and also as part of fact-check
EU a collaboration of European media
let's working to keep the record
straight ahead of the elections anything
that looks suspicious that we take a
closer look at that and and have it
smells funny especially the kind of
story that makes people angry or upset
or confirms people in their bias like I
knew Muslims this or I knew Trump death
after shank brands fake content with a
big red banner on his website he also
formally notifies Facebook which
immediately reduces the items visibility
in its news feeds Schenk is convinced
even small doses of disinformation can
be dangerous for democracy if you can
swing a few hundred votes in a certain
district or in a certain state that
might tip the balance and you cannot
make this coalition or that coalition
because once it has moved so it will
undoubtedly have an influence with so
much at stake across 28 countries
experts say we're likely to see intense
disinformation campaigns right up till
the final votes are cast let's bring in
the correspondent now put that report
together of where's teri Schultz good
morning Terry Terry can you tell us
what's what's the Kremlin's endgame in
this what does it want to achieve with
its disinformation campaigns what the
Kremlin wants is for voters to be
confused it doesn't necessarily need to
convince them of anything in particular
simply to make them doubt their leaders
doubt their media doubt each other even
to not know exactly what their their
future might hold and in in that
situation the Kremlin thinks perhaps
they'll be more likely to install
authoritarian leaders who are say
they'll keep them safe and maybe more
amenable to the to the kind of tactics
that Moscow likes and remember it at au
level it only takes one vote in many
cases to block things like sanctions or
energy projects so as Martin Schenk
explained I mean sometimes all you need
is a few hundred votes swayed this way
or that way to make a really big
difference but to be fair it's not only
Moscow doing this i'v big
big hacking campaigns have been traced
back to Iran to China to North Korea and
of course extremists in in Europe and
the United States are all using exactly
the same playbook it's just that we
happen to know perhaps the most about
the Russian efforts because they were so
successful in the 2016 US election and
in the brexit campaign as well okay
Terry your report points to the powerful
internet players Facebook and Google
being enlisted in the effort to prevent
a foreign political meddling but there
are plenty of reasons to ask if Silicon
Valley corporations of the right
partners or Europe to help protect the
integrity of its elections sure there's
a lot of discomfort about who would
decide what stays up and what gets taken
down what's a lie and what's the truth
and nobody really wants Google or
Facebook to be making that kind of
decision about political content but you
cannot do this without them and that has
certainly been proven by the fact that
there are millions and millions of fake
accounts floating out there who are
reaching just untold numbers of voters
and so what has been done is that the
the big platforms the social media
Giants have signed a code of conduct
with the European Commission that says
they're going to be more proactive about
taking down fake content about making
sure they know who paid for ads who paid
for articles and importantly there they
need to change the way they put fake
stories in their algorithm so if you've
got a fact checker saying and they've
proven a story is false then Facebook in
working with some of these consortiums
will then drop that story down so it
makes it more difficult for people to
see the fake content and make it go
viral and hopefully that's having an
impact teri Schultz for us from Brussels
thanks so much Terry for your report for
coming in this morning and checking out
all of this for us